the former french president nicolas
sarkozy has been sentenced to spend a
year in home detention for corruption
sarkozy was found guilty of illegal
campaign financing for his failed 2012
re-election bid
the court ruled he spent almost twice
the maximum amount allowed it comes
months after sarkozy was convicted in
another corruption case
let's go straight to natasha butler who
is live in paris natasha talk us through
exactly what the court announced today
yes nicholas sarkozy wasn't actually in
court here in paris to hear the verdict
but the judge found
sarkozy guilty of illegal campaign
financing his 13 co-accused also found
guilty on the same charges now sarkozy
has been sentenced to one year
jail but he can serve that out at home
under a house arrest if you like wearing
an electronic bracelet well his lawyers
have already said that he will appeal
now all this uh focuses uh on nicolas
sarkozy's uh campaign back in 2012 he
was running for re-election he actually
failed to be re-elected but his campaign
at the time was extremely lavish these
u.s style
mega rallies and they really set off for
non-bells because uh police
investigators accused sarkozy of
overspending basically his campaign team
spent nearly twice the legal limits set
by the french state for a presidential
campaign well the judge in the call said
that sarkozy knew that this was
happening there was also in addition to
this the fact that sarkozy's campaign
team used a pr firm called big malian to
set up a system of fake invoices the
judge said that there was no way that
sarkozy couldn't have known what was
happening and also that he had had
several warnings from his own
accountants that the costs were rising
so what is it that the french people
make of all this
it's hard to tell what the french public
make of it uh except for there is a
perception amongst some people in france
that uh corruption and nepotism are rife
in french politics and no doubt uh they
will feel that this decision uh
validates that i mean in terms of
nicolas sarkozy himself well clearly his
political ambitions are over he did
retire officially from french politics
in 2017 after another
failed election bid but some thought he
might try to run in 2022 but i think
with his corruption convictions it is
clear that he won't be able to do that
nevertheless he does remain popular
for many right-wing conservative voters
here in france who see him
as a figure of the right wing a very
strong president in the past the sort of
person that they might like to see
back in power i think though this trial
and verdict will though send out
certainly a sign as we come into the
next presidential election which will
take place next year in france it sends
out a message if you like to the
candidates and to uh the political
parties that they cannot act with
impunity
many thanks for that natasha butler
there in paris